Center it makes one into convention to
one coordinator on the other on the
other side and it replicates the data
inside that the epicenter now how fast
does it go
pretty much right we're not breaking any
laws of physics here I've had people ask
me well how fast is it's got to be like
microseconds Oh way across country
that's impossible unless you're using a
Large Hadron Collider I know this isn't
milliseconds but it's based on the
latency of those applications are
usually the latency of the wire so from
Amazon East Animas on web you know
you're talking about 70 80 milliseconds
it's pretty much wire speed inside the
data center is negligible so your
latency and replication is about your
wires so if you're really close by it's
really not that big of a deal but it's
something to manage the other basic
tenets of the Dynamo paper was this idea
of partition so acid compliant databases
are built on the silo of data so you
have to have this this database has to
be completely consistent and by itself
you cannot spread that nate around cap
is another theorem on that and that's
consistency availability to partition
these three things are what make no
sequel databases usable in this modern
era of trying to get web applications
running and so what these consistency
availability partition it comes down to
you get a pig - so what Cassandra does
is it has strong availability strong
partition tolerance and variable so what
that means a partition tolerance means
that now if I cut the link here both of
these sides should not stop working they
should just be fine now that doesn't
mean my data is a hundred percent
consistent that's what I'm that's what
I'm giving up but my my cluster is
available and ready to go
there's strong availability and
partition tolerance if I do that with my
bully gate system
the other side would shut down it would
stop say what about going into read-only
mode or something yeah that's it but
this is really not what I want but I'm
really active active data centers and
that's what our you know our users do to
save their users are doing active active
a lot I will show you this is the only
way to get it done
now there's application strategies to
manage this but it's completely do the
thing is you got out the database online
and ready for this
so what does this mean whatever the link
is restored the data is synchronized
from one side to the other how do we
synchronize timestamps the last part
right wheels very simple so if there is
data written over here native reach over
here they would be synchronizing if
they're connected but if for some reason
this node got newer data it would
synchronize you here once they were
restored everything's consistent it's
built into the system to synchronize
once about come on
so this is a very I think this is
probably one of the most compelling use
cases for the standard if you want to
guarantee uptime you cannot be in a
single data center a single data center
is going to fail you have to be
geographically dispersed and the people
that I work with with Cassandra usually
that's one of their first problems I got
a funny story so I think that I used to
running for started a lot of there and I
was mostly Oracle in some sequel server
and we had our Oracle database is
synchronizing to Santa Clara here at
South facility and so we were in
Northern Virginia Santa Clara we got so
far behind on a slab links laid black
that we just couldn't keep up and we
couldn't move that much of data across
the wire we couldn't catch up so what I
had to do is I had to have one of my
guys go down to our data center Northern
Virginia grab with a portal hard disk we
dumped all the data off of the Hargett
off of the Oracle system he ran to
Dulles Airport got on a plane flew
across country late
in San Jose blend up the static Clara
don't the data vacuum there just in time
before we got too far behind again where
it would never work again and then we
finally got the slave lag caught up and
everything was cool again everyone was
excited and that is stupid and the whole
time I thought this is stupid it's the
only way we're going to go there but
it's stupid we didn't have enough family
we couldn't get enough to get across you
cannot synchronize that very easily when
I start to first using Cassandra I was
like that that's magic that doesn't does
not real it does work really well
because that was the way it was designed
to work first and foremost so that's so
what about making sure your data is
consistent probably one thing that I
hear the most about data consistency is
is near and dear to my heart because
that's what your contribution is
expecting but you as an application for
a program need to manage it so what
about that
so with replication factor how often
your data is replicated we also we have
this flip side which is our consistency
level now I told you that with cap there
is a suitable consistency meaning you
could be more consistent or less
consistent kind of like my kids and in
this case what I'm going to do is I'm
going to show you an example of how that
would work in an application so my
client is writing to a random node and
that need is being parallel way now to
the replicas yeah if I pick different
consistency levels that's what I'm
actually asking my client the response
from let me explain so the first and
foremost client consistency level is all
all means I want every single replicas
to acknowledge that that dating is on
bits so if I have a replication factor
of three all three replicas have to say
I got that's pretty intense but that
gets the job done right no one will ever
say that your data thinking
with that kind of setting and that's
probably not one you'll ever use because
what that means if you could never have
a note go offline the note goes offline
you can't get every single replication
system but if you do this what's a
little more forgiving and probably much
more useful is this idea of quorum
quorum means that I want 51% of mine
that because to everything I say now is
now our crowd you know yeah we got some
consistent level replication factors
going on right on so okay what was I
talking about
oh you Sandra that's right yeah again
seems like I do this all the time
okay so consistency level we're at a
gate at quorum thank you back to the
track quorum each 51% of my nose 51% of
my replicas are responding so whenever I
say I'm gonna upset my data please and
here's an exact example so when the
client writes the gate into the core
could the coordinator picks it up and
says I'm gonna parallel write that out
well I get three different responses
back from those replicas I got five
micro second 12 micro second left 500
micro second acknowledgment well these
two will make it back to the notice
those two will win because I now have
51% my nose responding they're quick so
that means the coordinator is going to
respond back really quickly with 12
micro second within 12 micro second
saying Scott well meanwhile this one
just look to even respond but there's
your slow you missed the bus but don't
matter it's okay
I already talked to the client you're
cool it doesn't mean that they dated in
replicating it just means that from the
client standpoint and this is killer you
as a developer can pick this choice the
developer saying I want a good
consistency but at one speed so quorum
is going to get you more speed because
now I'm really expecting two of these to
respond back to get my response back to
the client
cool but I got GU consistency how does
that as well so what this corner gives
me is hey my data opportunity mark you
know my systems gene decided to reboot
one of my server in the middle of the
day instead of that turning into a big
red thing on that plasma screen you know
that one and no that's not a problem
just read me rebooting come back online
you didn't even know it was gone and
that's really cool for your
infrastructure that's what you want for
your end users and that's definitely
what you want for your sleep you kind of
consumers you do not would have gone
painter duties when this thing dies and
you gotta wake up 3 a.m. and punch it
I've been there how many have you been
on paper duty oh yeah
so don't have to do that my favorite
Cassandra story my personal production
experience there was a major outage and
one of the zones and in Amazon on a
Saturday I didn't notice until Monday
that was really cool I came in there
like why are these nodes great and then
somebody said well there was a outage
and amplitude zones and so the scene huh
they're gone ok well Bree boom
application didn't even care
it was kept on truckin there's a little
degrading but I mean I had plenty no
those are the big deals but that was my
first moment where I'm like I didn't
care that's an awesome experience
melodic to see her stories like that you
know when we all get together you know
when we talk about Greek beard it's
called the summit we always tell these
stories to each other oh yeah that's
enough that one time I lost half my
cluster oh yeah so this is what we want
though is we want the consistency and
the consistency means and I can lose
those nose and my date is safe because
more that is the most important thing a
database had better save the data I'm
like manga which does but that's ok they
got a nice little JSON interface
so whatever we whatever we're feeling
especially well this isn't even that
cowboy but we could even take this down
to something like one now one means I
just want one note to tell me I got it
perfect now as an application developer
I may be setting my logs I may be
putting logs into the native into my
database if it takes a while for it to
get in there or I don't really care
about the consistency as much one is
awesome
I mean really you'd be really surprised
at how much data gets set at 1 in red at
1 because people are feeling pretty
comfortable with Brady Cassandra and
those consistency levels work very well
now when I use a 1 it may notice just
this one that's where the
acknowledgement but it's still
replicating the data from here to here
that replication is still happening
doesn't mean I don't want consistency it
means I don't want to wait for the
response and that that's where your
speed is so if you're reading here
you're writing up one that's what you
get and I need it I need to reiterate
something
the consistency level is set at read and
write so I could write a quorum and read
it one or maybe I want to bias my rights
I could write it one but I need to make
sure whatever time I read is consistent
I can read form so I just mix and match
these modes around us I need to so I can
get the consistency as a programmer than
I want I'm putting a hand and putting
this in the hands to the architects and
the developers you specify how you want
it and that's the way it'll work and
it's just it's just a tunable I want to
be faster a lot more consistent so the
other one that's done in the middle here
is this local form now 51 percent of the
nodes is awesome if I made one data
center but if I have to cross over that
big chasm from east to west us that's 70
milliseconds now I'm not so excited
about form because I just seven email a
second hit on my budget I don't want
that so local quorum is in the middle
that means I might have a quorum of data
inside my local data center it still
refuse to be
but it's cool I'm not asking for that to
be the response requirement so it's
still replicating still doing quorum but
only inside my little dataset awesome
okay so what about the single node
failure and this is this is alright so
here is my Monday morning experience so
when we have this single node failures
when we have this replication factor in
consistency level at the right the right
levels this is part of our planning then
you have success
I've built a built a system now that is
pretty resilient
it is tough it can take a lot of abuse I
put it in Amazon I was expecting a
little but and I got it then this is and
this is what I'm looking at right here
this is a VAR f of our F of three with a
consistency level of quorum and that's
what I did so 51% of those nodes
acknowledged it I'm good I'm sleeping
still and when that note comes back
online because we stored this
information it will be synchronized and
be ok so how does that work so this node
goes offline the coordinator stores
what's called a hint insert little
misunderstood but really what it is the
coordinator says oh that dudes offline
I'll hold on to his data form because
he'll be back and so when the node does
come back online it broadcasts inside
hey I'm back guys what's up and they're
like hey welcome back we've got some
data for you here you go and so they
give the data over that note re
synchronizes everything's consistent and
comes back online it says alright I'm
ready to go
that is great because when you reboot a
node the last thing you want to do is
figure out if the data is consistent
that's not the problem that question
already
if four goes down then I'm kind of
transfer
well it's Note 4 and O three go down
just note for a while I'm talking to it
yeah the client will get a timeout and
they don't try the next note over which
is a great segue sir thank you let's
talk about drivers yeah hold on this
minute what oh and you broke my segue
why can't go for be wet
well if you're writing to note 4 it'll
write to node 1 and no 2 has a
coordinated right but it'll store the
hints for node number 3 if known for it
goes down then you won't have a forum
anymore that's for sure then your fact
that you should be writing at 1 yeah so
having more than one fit with
replication factor of 3 having more than
two nodes offline is not good but right
so let's plan for them let's add a lot
more nodes maybe all right that's where
that other data center it's going to
sink now if you're in another datacenter
you're good to go
why don't we hold off on our questions
and still get company I just pop the
cork on that and they're gonna come
flooding in so thank you
the holdup we're all going back we're
going to answer tons of questions and I
I actually planned on most of the night
beam map I'm gonna be here until at
least 1 a.m. so all right so let's talk
about drivers drivers are a critical
piece of the puzzle here the server
itself does a lot it does a lot but the
client needs to be involved and that's
why I say with application programmers
you've got a lot of power that's cool we
never had power before we rolled into
the DBA you're gonna do one with my
database so the driver has a lot to do
with this because think about how you
said you said consistency level that
happens in the application code but
there's other things that the drivers
need to do no data stacks oh by the way
I work for the exact data stacks we
write drivers for Java or C sharp
we have Python and we have other ones
coming and those drivers all do pretty
much the same type of thing so they make
it really easy
to connect to the database it should be
a real big trick so here's an example
I'm just gonna create a session to
create to connect to the database I have
some contact points because I'm talking
to a cluster I have a whole bunch of
contact points maybe my entire cluster
it also has the ability to discover my
cluster fighting I send it to one node
it can pass the cluster hey do you give
you the rest of the nodes and you will
come back with this list of here's all
the servers out there and then that's
what makes the client know they
communicate with the rest of these
there's mustard and what I did here is I
created just a simple cluster with all
kinds of nifty little gadgets like I
want a load balancing policy like how I
want to load balance across all my
dough's with a retry policy like if it
fails I have a certain point I don't
want everything to come back and I just
say build my cluster and then once I've
done it I connect
that's it now I have a session I can
execute queries off of it it's really
easy and that makes it very usable for
an application program so one of how do
we do this load balancing which i think
is one of the more compelling things
about running a large-scale cluster is
now we change the way we talk to the
cluster so whatever we have a lot of
nodes ashame if we can talk to them all
at the same time in parallel so our
driver for instance uses these thread
pools and drive into any brokers to
connect to the nodes and make sure that
your connection is very fluid but also
in parallel so we have this like for
instances they call them token aware no
strategy
which means that your dated has
parameter against is in certain replicas
by design because we have a consistent
hash well the driver will go find that
data for you in the right spot so you
don't have to go through a coordination
face very efficient but when you're
setting and getting 100,000 rows per
second
and that's pretty easy to do then this
kind of helps being able to do this in
parallel and that's part of what our
driver data and so things like fault
tolerance and failure so what happens if
that node dies in the middle
request well it doesn't bring down my
application as a matter of fact my
client isn't even gonna tell me if you
can manage it our client will fail back
it'll say no I didn't like that I'm
gonna try another spot those timeouts
somebody asked two seconds or less it
feels fast so if you have or if there's
even a place where you reboot a note it
will tell the client damn that knows
going online don't send any more traffic
to it and so there isn't even a failure
point for that it doesn't even have to
fail once to do it right so what what we
now get is a really cool potential
architectures now this is what I like to
talk to it's building a large-scale web
app architectures rating any kind of
application architecture so I just did
this talk at no sequel now it was about
building antifragile applications oh by
the way to talk a little bit about
Cassandra but it was mostly about
building these these this is a hard
thing to build cuz I built it and it was
hard so what we have here is I'm gonna
give you an example application and what
the underlying what it is is kind of
irrelevant but just to give you an idea
of like the use cases that are pretty
typical for a user of Cassandra so they
may have a US and a Europe data center
they created these silos of their
application for those users so you're
paying users u.s. users so they have a
web tier the service tier some caching
and then they have a cluster of standard
O's and they have individual data
centers of those now in a normally
offering situation they're using service
based DNS routing so some ones in Europe
they go to the European datacenter is
someone's in the US they go to the US
data center there when they're adding
data to them to the application that
data is immediately synchronized
asynchronously to the other side so my
data is fake and it's moving across so
like disaster recovery plans are dealt
with I don't have a dr website and
acta back so with this configuration now
I can survive things like a single node
failure doesn't bring down my data
center it doesn't bring down my
applications people in Europe could care
less that I have a node offline that's
exactly what I want both times but in
the worst case scenarios when I lose an
entire data center now I got problems
because if I had a single like a single
silo of applications here and my data
tier wasn't on board with the idea of
being replicated I'm gonna have trouble
big trouble
and I think this is actually pretty
typical oops
so whenever we have this particular case
in hand this person's not going to be
like that but whenever we're using
Cassandra their data is now over here so
all the European data was over here at
any limit and so whenever we lose a data
center we just evacuated we've failed
over those connections to here now
granted if someone's using a web
connection from say UK to the US that
could be super fast but it's online and
their data thing so this actually
happens quite often I'll tell you who
does it to and they do it on purpose
just to prove that they can do it every
day and this kind of architecture is
very doable
whenever I was doing this say 10 years
ago it was very difficult because of one
thing the data tier the data tier is
very very difficult it's the hardest
part to get in this mode replicating
like this
if you follow it Yahoo did they did some
amazing things to make that work
Facebook rewrote the query engine my
sequel to figure out how to make that
work first like five years ago that was
a bad idea
another stuff but there there's not an
easy solution until you start changing
the type of technology we use using -
Sandra works so I'm going to go through
a few users like I said I left a lot of
room at the end for questions cuz I know
I'm gonna have a time I always do so
that's cool but I'm going to talk about
some users and so what are they doing
how do they do it
just jog your ideas and then start the
question about so everybody that was
about Netflix I almost hesitated to put
that up there but they are pros so if
you haven't heard about Netflix using
Cassandra surprise you've never heard
about that because they always talk
about it but it's cool because they
house really interesting use cases and
they've advanced the game quite a bit
they have made Cassandra what it is
today
I'm gonna say that right because they
have figured out a lot of things at
scale and they've proven a lot of things
at scale I looked it up today that had
that company has an 18 billion dollar
market cap and they are 100% on
Cassander yeah
so what does that mean they were lie
they have 18 billion dollars of market
cap that is hinging on the fact that
their data served on a Cassandra I think
that's a pretty strong validation that's
why I leave that slide up there Reed
Hastings who's the CEO their bet the
farm on that and it worked and why
because they are in a heavily
distributed environment they're in
Europe they're in South America there is
North America and they have to be online
all the time what's really interesting
is when I was in Europe last week I can
watch Netflix and I paused my video
in Dublin my mom my video was at the
same place again why could that be it
was replicated in a Kassandra them
actually 144 244 another cluster which I
used to work with so that was just not
magic it was just how it was built and
actually they just take advantage of the
fact that that data gets replicated like
that now what does that mean like user
counts
I mean just straight up user accounts if
you have an account on Netflix your name
is the extorter to standard very simple
static tables playlists like I said your
playlists are all in there now have you
seen that new feature or you can have
playlists with multiple inside your
house I helped a little bit with that
that was a cool day tomorrow that's all
I can standard payments so they're doing
payments when you when you give them
money they do payments inside here they
actually figured out how to do some of
like the PCI compliance and Amazon which
is I think a big American nothing but
they figure that out and they grab
gather a lot of statistics every
everything you watch a Netflix that time
series data is streaming back to a
Cassandra cluster Cassandra does
excellent time series data that is
probably one of the primary and first
class cases for kidnap for Cassandra is
time series data the Internet of Things
streaming data from blogs that sort of
thing just because of the way it works
it works very well with that now I put
this up here because they do something
very unique and I think it's something
that to emulate and I tell people all
the time I'm consulting do this they
have this thing called the simian army
if anyone ever heard of the simian army
or the chaos monkey all right not too
many all right that's good because it's
really crazy concept they have build
services they can go around and kill
other services so the chaos monkey will
take out random servers in their Amazon
infrastructure during the day
in production one now it's a plastic I
did that at my job people would kill me
right but they do that because they want
everybody on board with the fact that
your infrastructure is not safer it's
gonna go away
deal with it and when it goes away and
it has a problem it's your problem fix
it so the developers all the way down
are aware of the fact that there's that
monkey out there it's going to take out
their server they have other monkeys to
like late month then they have chaos
comm that takes out large claws of
entire infrastructures in Amazon so that
just you know take away anything if you
can do that in your infrastructure
you're playing a different game a cool
game it dot that means you could survive
a lot of problems and I ask people you
know what I talk about I do consulting
work and they're like well I would like
you burn stuff on work or our mainframe
yeah I'm still talking people on being
that I'm like oh okay can we unleash you
can smokey in your environment we're
going to take the damage can you imagine
an oracle server just being turned off
click sorry mom
no you don't do that and so it's just a
different airline we've changed the game
because what happens now everybody is on
this now right I mean I expect my
clicked on stuff I mean I complain
whenever it's slow if it's offline it's
almost unheard of you know there was a
I'm gonna have it's funny cuz I decide
on this but everyone easy to Graham went
down for a morning of Saturday morning
they're like there's a whole day with no
one knew what they ate for breakfast
because everyone didn't take your
picture their breakfast right and it was
because we've all just it's like this
thing that's it has to be online all the
time so we've changed the game so how
about how about somebody else besides
Netflix my favorite Spotify Spotify
isn't awesome and I like have to mention
to Netflix they happen to chewier that
are a big committee working there for
Cassandra Cassandra is an Apache product
we are stewards of a lot of it we have a
lot of committers that work for us we
don't know there's a commander that
works at Netflix he commits code all the
time and that's part of the what's
really cool about working with a little
bit source if you want to know if you
don't believe a damn thing I said
tonight go download the source code it's
all out there it's free go do it
it's yours if you want to modify it if
you said you know why's that quorum
thing is exactly what I wanted change it
it's cool do it Spotify another big user
Cassandra millions and millions I mean I
think 85 million users there's some
crazy number like that they got a lot of
people using Spotify around the world oh
and they have a committer as well
because they're so into Cassandra they
have a committee working there see the
trend there so they have 1 billion
playlists being managed by Cassandra
thank God cuz I'm a huge Spotify user
and I'm kind of happy that they're using
Cassandra cause it's online if I were
using like music now am i selling I
probably be laughing so they have 30
Cassandra clusters running all the time
yeah 50 terabytes data so you know hey
Big D 2 gurus it seems pretty big KQ
terabytes and that's not even close to
the death terrible hand of mine I got a
cluster out there
they're doing 40,000 requests per second
on playlist just playlist alone so when
you know people are playing with their
playlist that's getting updated now
what's really interesting about how they
do things there is that there they're
definitely a hacker mentality but
they're very conservative when it comes
to Cassandra
they don't they don't live on the
bleeding edge so there's a lot they have
a lot of old Cassandra and their
infrastructure also big user fusion-io
if you ever see a huge my talk but one
of them how one of the use cases that
they have with this playlist is that
they're able to they're almost using it
like isn't getting did you know that you
could rewind your playlist and go see
previous versions of your playlist on
Spotify you can go and look at different
the history of your playlist in Spotify
because all of its being stored in these
really wide rows and Cassandra they
figured out how to do like a ledger in
system and when you update it does
things around the world I was just in
London and Dublin my Spotify lists were
there and they're good to go I changed
them there I came back to the US they're
fine so then that's what I expect now
now whatever I know when I was in
Australia the same thing that's what I
expect now this is the world we live in
now I expect my stuff to be cool I don't
want to make an experience where I'm
getting spoiled so Spotify has has
really turned out to be a great user and
they're also a good community member
Thank You speed ups and stuff like that
but man you talked about scale there
there yeah imagine mentioned Instagram
they went down for a while but those
before they switched over so Facebook
it's funny because Facebook was where
Cassandra got started and it escaped and
they brought it back so Instagram which
is a facebook they are pretty heavy
users of Cassandra and so well you know
of course Instagram they do photos and
things like that so what they're using
it for in Amazon
is two things your security audits so
that making sure there's no fraudulent
activity and there's a very high
activity stream of data like as you had
things you delete things everything is
going on in your account they're
watching for fraud and that has to be
you have to track every single usage
that every user does on their account
that's something that's very difficult
to you unless you have a high
transaction system now along the way
they were using a lot of posters for
news feeds so you know things like hey I
posted a new picture if you're following
people on the time the Instagram those
are your news feeds they all sales
switched over to a 12 node cluster and
Amazon that is running the entire thing
we're talking 20,000 rights per second
and 15,000 reads per second on that
cluster all day long so these are these
are not playing our users now we have
small users oh yeah
we have some very small users but it's
really cool to see that they can go from
small to big they need to there's I
can't talk about the start of the work
with but I think they're good to go huge
but right now they have very small
cluster for knows or free notes actually
if they go big the last thing that
they're gonna have to worry about is
making their database Instagram big it
just just going to be a problem if they
Steve small of their data sink they
don't care they're fun I don't think but
these are the kind of users using
consumer so that's all I had I have left
a lot of room for questions so let's
open up the floodgates Suzy are you
ready for happiness all right good
questions of where we're eating what are
we writing that's the question
yeah I was getting again so when we say
reads and writes per second in the
Cassandra database exactly what is that
let's quantify what it really is was
quantified whatever right now I'm gonna
go back to this oh by the way Netflix
they do over a million right
second all day long and that may give
you can easily cut one customer so it's
not just tens of thousands it's a lot
let's go back to this line right here
okay so I'm right and a read is your
data this is a data store two days days
so whenever I present data I dream I
expect it to be durably saved on a disk
and in the case of Cassandra I want to
replicate so when I say I want to write
some data to a cluster I expect three
nodes to durably right that to a disk
that is it right so my kid is now safe
and sound sitting on it is stored in a
certain structure maybe one row and one
column or one row and several columns in
a row in a stream so it could be in the
data set or a single data point in its
answer exactly the terminology as an
insert like will seek you out for pest
oh I'm sorry
let's go so that's now be an SQL insert
or update would be a write a read would
be a select I want that data back in the
same consistency level as well so I'm
let's maybe use like SQL terminology I'm
doing a million inserts per second and
I'm doing a million selects per second
and but the important thing is that my
data is now on the disk when I do the
insert it's durable safe and it's
replicated and when I do the read is
coming off of the disk in a consistent
manner as well well
it's not always one to one mapping
because the way that it works a single
node so what happens is a single node
have the way that the right path is in
Cassandra is that when you write get
into a single node
so a single rose equal column it goes to
the commit log that's the durability and
then it writes an inch of memory and it
will stay in there now as you're writing
data it continuously that a really fast
pace it starts filling up those data
structures of memory because of the way
that it works this is how we can sustain
a high write of Rick in high write rate
rate of write figures is that once that
memory structure fills out it will flush
that entire row structure to the disk in
one sequential right so that's a very
different thing about Sandra is not
doing random reads and writes is doing
sequential reads and writes which is a
very different pattern and it's very
good and on a lot of days especially
SSDs but it's so it's writing out a long
piece of data now what that means when
you do a read it's optimized instead of
doing a lot of random will read you're
reading from one seat point we're doing
an entire sweep on the disk spinning
disk that makes a big difference right
you're doing one seat that's where the
key to hit it on SSDs not a big of a
game but you're reading a swath of data
at one shot that's where the speed comes
in that's why time series data is so
good at Cassandra because you think
about it gets an order to setup data I
want to read everything I want
everything that hasn't from this time to
this time but you can ask that Cassandra
know that and it will be a single seek
on the disk and then one pull off again
very efficient you can have I've seen
users with millions of Rights with p95
of nine milliseconds ten milliseconds
easy because when you get your bait up
alright and it's working well you're you
probably need to point out as a memory
so because it's a lock file structure
you're gonna replace what's in memory
but when that data is written out to the
disk all right one thing that we keep in
mind and this is a different concept as
well with Cassandra when that memory
table is flushed out to distance called
an SS table it only writes that table
one time that file is never written to
again now that actually pretty handy if
you've ever done backups and you have
movie file problems you never have an
open file but that means you have a
buildup of files there's a process that
runs in the background called compaction
and that combines these SS cables these
data files
it doesn't merge short so it'll take
several of those to emerge or create one
new file on the compaction process is
very very understood it's used in
several different technologies HBase
uses compaction chrome level compaction
and the Chrome browser so leveldb uses
compaction so compaction is a way that
you can quickly write out your data and
then the cost later in IO is in the
sequential item that's why very it's
very good on local modern hardware
yeah so varied some monitoring how do
you monitor a flustered well alright so
gated stacks one of the things that we
do is we build we have a product on top
center and if watches multiple clusters
and it's a great product because
whenever you have a lot of servers they
tend to gang up on right so you have you
have a single pane of view on that we
could manage it through the church
servers on and off we also have another
product called deaf Center which allows
you to read write queries directly into
your database and that's a separate it's
an open source product download it right
now but we provide management tools for
Cassandra you can do it in open source
but we provide a value add to oh you can
just go to native snacks calm and
download right away I mean it everything
you hear and see today is legally free
download